my good friend from good-morning
football Kyle Bryant back here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Kyle rich
I'm thrilled to be on and I don't give a
damn if I'm late
happy birthday you beautiful man thank
you appreciate that Kyle
thank you very much daily or not a
dollar short anymore I appreciate it
thank you
that's okay rich I just want to know if
it doesn't bean 50-plus and a Michigan
man doesn't make you eligible to be the
Buccaneers quarterback it does as a
matter of fact I've been asked I've been
asked to do that but I said you know
what get in there let t be 12 B that guy
even though I did take to Instagram to
have a blue steel selfie yesterday oh
yeah and you know I'm kind of feeling
like I'm a I'm a fine wine on that front
the remarkable thing though is that I'm
on my blue steel selfie Chris Brockman
responded with a fascinating comment
that I forget that I'm now the same age
that Wilford Brimley was somehow when he
was in the cocoon which is remarkably
wilford brimley cocoon house and I think
the movie the firm he looks like he's 40
years old I know it's the right thing to
do but I can't imagine again we checked
on the ages of Messrs Cronin amici and
Guilford as well as the ages of of what
Miz Andy's Don Ameche all of it they
were all in their 70s and and the young
and who I guess was you know putting the
whoopee cushions under the seats just
you know not not acting his age Wilford
Brimley was 50 Wars like the juju Smith
Shuster - the cast of batteries not
included rats that's the next
cross-examination the juju Smith Shuster
does that make Don Ameche or Hume Cronyn
the Antonio Brown and so it makes that
or far as I'm concerned mr. Crowe
and amici kept working though throughout
they were hey you know I've been demand
where's the other one is unemployed
was team MVP and required the other guy
I don't know oh my gosh now Jay Cutler
did you think Jay had this in him Carl
let's be honest here
well at this point I think we can just
start calling him Jay exotic yeah I
would have thought if in the quarantine
period you would think that the market
on a wild southerner getting in the cage
with animals would have been cornered
yes by Joe Maldonado passage current
incarcerated felon and yet he wasn't
even the best one a color just
completely took that game from him I'm
riveted because we have a whodunit and I
don't know what the answer was I only
saw the teaser video that someone's
killing chickens he thought it might be
the cat bunny throughout a bunch of
other theories did we get an answer yet
cuz I'm gonna edge of my seat well he
has Instagram doubt an apology today I
don't know if you had that information
on Good Morning football today yeah he
instagrammed out because he did a couple
of videos yesterday and then he
instagrammed out an apology to the cat
while I'm not sorry you were accused of
these vicious acts I'm reading verbatim
I will be the bigger person and admit I
was wrong you are not the suspect we are
looking for take it as a compliment for
your savage ways of life carry on cat
you know and so it's interesting at
carry on cat he finishes up with a very
very Seussian type of three words
sentence but Don if you can put that
Instagram up one more time the words
that left out at me interestingly enough
was I will be the bigger person and
admit I was wrong and as I said in the
top of the show those are words I think
Mike March is still waiting here Kyle oh
it's beautiful
you should hear them it's funny because
you know Jay is apologizing for damaging
the reputation of cats yes and yet I
still see no apology for all the damage
he's done to bears because I think there
might be some culpability of there too
yeah Kyle Brian everybody I'm giving you
a round of applause I didn't expect this
one I didn't expect uh I didn't expect
Jay to take to Instagram and then turn
his life into content cuz he looked like
what what what were the words you use
before to describe the way he utter
disdain and and sheer indifference sheer
by the way which was a great opening act
years ago when other Justine opened up
for sheer indifference oh yeah that's
what he showed when he was in the the
the Cavallari reality show you know but
I think I saw utter disdain an Ozzfest
2002 incredible set they did opening for
I don't know who it was probably Ozzie
himself but that show started and the
whole pitch of the show is you've got
Kristen and she's doing the thing and
then J is the begrudge 'add bit getting
dragged along almost like a hostage it
felt like but you know rich when they
just American Idol they probably thought
Paula Abdul is gonna be the star of the
show and you bring in Randy and the
singers you want some of that Simon
Cowell disgust yes you do especially now
and everybody's annoyed with everything
it becomes really really relatable that
Cutler is over it and rolling his eyes
because guess what the rest of us are
doing I also noticed that he'd had the
same body language during his Instagram
feed of Kyle as you would have when he
had throwing like six interceptions one
day and throwing and throwing in Windows
that Ryan Fitzpatrick would look out and
go no I'm not gonna try that you know it
was a remarkable symmetry is this thing
I watched him once walk off the field
against the 49ers having just completely
collapsed I think it was four
interceptions and three of them were in
the red zone
and if you were to freeze his shoulders
and neck it's exactly like he looks
walking into whatever boutique he was
being dragged into or in a chicken coop
there's like nothing has changed I love
stayed the same and we love it I do too
either way bears lost that game 10-6
Cutler had five picks in that game
November 12 2009 never change
and again I'm so I'm just so glad we he
had it in him
you know we kind of need all this stuff
so what do you think is the biggest
football story that's not involved with
covin what are you guys talking about
that you're it you've been enjoying
hitting you know a lot of bucks a lot of
Tampa Bay and I know right so we had a
question this morning and it was which
Tampa Bay Buccaneer are you looking at
as you know at this point like we're
turning up anything we can just talk
about it I think we already did the
which stranger things character would
Baker Mayfield be second player are you
looking at Kyle you're talking to
somebody by the way Carl you're talking
to somebody who kept the light on during
a lockout on NFL Network on game NFL
Total Access since 2011 so I I
absolutely hear you
so which Buccaneer am I looking at is
that the the and is that an open-ended
question fascinating watch man I mean
you can't go Brady cuz that's the
obvious right Ariane's yeah you could go
Arians but to me it's Gronk
to me it's Krunk well you know Florida
man Gronk without ya Belichick standing
over his shoulder without without Gronk
kind of peering out his peripheral to
see what the coach is thinking that
Aryans just the no risk at no biscuit
coach Plus Gronk Plus Florida to me I
think is rife with must-see television
that's what I would say to that answer I
I would I would have which is Gronk
especially since also he that theory yes
that kind of like yes Bush would caddy
swim feel
115 you're waited your whole life for
this is in Florida yes I went deep if
you look at the Bucks schedule yes in
December in November there's no cold
water games all the road games are on
the road there at Atlanta I think and
are at Detroit so none of that like late
December Foxborough actions yes he's got
a coach who just likes to bust chops and
have cocktails and he's he's know
playing in a stadium with it literally
has a damn pirate ship and as it fires
cannons it's like a child's paradise I
think we're seeing the best Gronk this
year and I had a theory about the bat
Gronk I want to bounce this off of you
yes if the hypothetical plays out that
we get great Gronk this year yes it
really work he's loose he's fierce see
the red zone maniac he's spiking eight
his dance it just it we get to ten out
of ten Gronk it was a real success and
just out there saying taking that year
off was the best thing I've ever done my
body feels great my head feels great
is there not a possibility for others
adapting the gap year strategy I'm
looking at guys who are veterans who
have been beat up and injured who have
made a ton of money on and off the field
who are like you know what I think I
could use a year if you look at somebody
like a JJ Watt or a Richard Sherman who
could retire for a year on retire and
immediately a bunch of teams with wanna
sign them
if Gronk says is the best thing I've
ever done maybe that's the copycat trend
incentive everyone's just retiring early
now maybe you just need a year to go on
the beach and do a little commentating
make some money do some video games then
come back ready to go if it works for
him I think it could work for other guys
yeah go out and you know dance with the
Laker Girls and and and and go to Times
Square and and and Spike Steve Harvey's
leggo ahead yeah well do the masked
singer do the masked singer where it was
so obvious it was him and by the way
speaking of Fox shows my kids are so
locked in on JJ Watt TJ watt and Derek
watt do an ultimate tag have you seen
this have you seen this show Kyle okay
I've seen the show American Gladiators
there's a big
fan of Nitro and Gemini but that was 20
years ago and I've not seen ultimate tag
I've heard about it like tell me about
it I got to watch there's some Running
Man vibe to it because the taggers the
taggers all have nicknames and and slick
videos when they're introduced as the
taggers okay it's it's okay you know
it's and and and then there's the wat
brothers who are the hosts on the show
and I'm an expert at this because my
kids not only watch it live they then
rewatch it over and over and over again
throughout the week and TJ TJ and Derek
are standing there next to Jay Jay who's
in the middle almost every time and JJ
is the prompter reader he does all the
nuts and bolts okay Derek and TJ
sometimes do the interviews with the the
the people who are avoiding the tags the
contestants and it was clear that early
on they needed to come up with a
catchphrase and it's a catchphrase that
I run up and say to my kids all the time
and they roll their eyes cuz I'm the dad
it starts with Jay Jay Jay saying it's
time to play some tag like literally
says that that's how it starts okay
let's go here we go it's now where it's
now ready you okay so-and-so is ready
you know flame is ready to do the
tagging and she's like got this red hair
and you know she's ready to go tell you
and now so-and-so is ready it's time to
play some tag like I want to show every
time he says it like 90 times during the
program and my kids ready running on the
field at Gillette Stadium
hey it's know it's time to play some
time and you gonna say that after a man
rich maybe that's that's one of the
Alzheimer's and if this Jay is the
de-facto host are you in some kind of
way linking JJ Watt and richard dawson
because that sounds like the perfect
human well JJ's less evil than richard
Dawson in this only inner ear in terms
of in terms of fake reality tag show
hosts he's much nicer in terms of game
show host
he doesn't kiss a single person during
ultimate tears a running man home game
when he gives that out just on the other
day still as good as it was no ago we
got again you know do we have okay ask
him ask him the new poll question that
we had a new poll Kyle based on Mike del
two foes blind spot in his movie viewing
experience you could only watch one you
can only watch one wedding crashers
old-school mmm-hmm you have to choose
which one that's the two options that's
it you can only watch one okay so the
answer is old-school and I'll tell you
why okay because you get a lot more
Farrell for your buck as good as he is
and wedding crashers it's a hilarious
cameo with the nunchucks and the
meatloaf but it's way late in the movie
give me a bigger factor of Vince and
Will Ferrell over a lot of Owen Wilson
saying we're after further consideration
on my part that's the right answer old
school is the right answer
you don't get wedding crashers if
there's no old school okay wedding I'm
old school all right rich were you a
were you a red wedding crashers guys
fantastic don't get me wrong but this is
you know this is the to one and the
finals of the bracket Oh somebody's got
to go no III would go wedding crashers
over old school I really well really I
just think first of all I love Bradley
Cooper in his role I think Carly Cooper
in his role is fantastic isla Fisher is
just a a drop of honey on the planet and
I do like Owen Wilson I find him very
funny I think this is Vince Vaughn it at
his finest outside of swingers and Will
Ferrell cameo at the end is fantastic
like his meatloaf line is better than
his lines in old school and I was I will
take that to the mat even though I know
and I used I would think Jane Seymour
also a drop of honey I would only
counter that if you look at the apex
scene like what is the funniest scene in
both movies they both have a lot it's
tough to beat that Snoop Dogg in the
middle of his set and then a fully naked
Will Ferrell coming on stage and then
streaking through the town
his wife picking up in a car they're
saying up a little bit cold out there
and his line is is the Wendy's still
open like that whole sequence is so good
I just think of the apex the apex factor
I have to go I have to go though okay
and since you know lines very well
what's yeah what's I don't know if
you've ever been asked this I've never
asked you this question come on your
favorite line that you ever delivered on
Days of Our Lives three seasons right
for four seasons through three years you
played the you played the character of
Philip Kuryakin I know that right that's
right absolutely Greek gentleman you can
tell by me I'm a Greek man and yeah
three and a half years they don't even
do seasons rich it's just a year round
okay 52 weeks a year and never stopped
okay so which is your favorite line
where it doesn't have to include a music
swell at the end but that would be
helpful what would it be
Carl that you delivered your favorite
line I had a walk-off okay rich and
people ask me all the time and my
department days our lives was I killed
no I was not I had the airport scene bag
over the shoulder walk down the jetway
yes stop on your mark pause turn over
the left shoulder whimsically and look
at your love and I let my lover's named
Belle yes and as I walk down the jetway
yes I had a lot of weight that I was
carrying fill up about this the town of
Salem had rejected him and how he was
going to be triumphant and the line was
Belle I'm not leaving this town this
town's leaving me
and I want and I know it doesn't it
doesn't even make sense because I
literally deliver it as I was about to
physically I had the single tear and
I'll tell you how you separate the
adults from the children on soaps uh
everybody can cry on command it's just
like taking batting practice an mo but
you got a crying command but when I
started there the great great Deidre
Hall who plays Marlena for 30 years yes
I saw the director come up to her and
say Deidre can we get a tear here for
your close up before we go to commercial
and sell fabric softener can we get this
here and she literally said to him would
you like the tear from the left eye or
the right eye stop that's cool that's
the Michael Jordan of soaps I never
could go ambidextrious I think I was
only a southpaw crier but those how you
know the real man you expect they can go
either I so this town I'm not leaving
this town this towns leaving me right I
don't even know if it makes sense the
check cleared and I was leaving the show
that's the last line I have a stiff
drink with that Kyle I always enjoy our
chats man you take care of yourself
we'll chat again soon rich I'm gonna go
out and play with the kids right now
guess what it's time to play sometimes
[Music]
it's timed got to do it one more time
again this is it's time to play some tag
like that like you got a gang nice yeah
you're right it's fitting it's time to
play some tag that's how he does it okay
okay can you do it I'm not gonna play
some tag some tag is gonna play me
[Applause]
looking over his shoulder these are the
days of Collbran on the richesse he's
not leaving the show the show's leaving
him Collbran everybody ain't a fantastic
man that guy make cracks me up
racking what a great spot by Kyle Bryan
Oh fantastic good morning football every
morning on and anti-felon Network hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here